I put Brad Pitt Jake Gyllenhaal and me
puts Bradley Cooper in the road okay
would you go to bang and go I'm number
you want me to do an F marry kill not F
marry kill who's the guy yeah track
marry kill all right that's Mary Coe go
ahead all right who are the guys again I
forgot already Bradley Cooper Brad Pitt
Brad Pitt Jake Gyllenhaal all right
sorry Brad Pitt but you're getting
killed
Wow oh you like that dad no dad how's
that pretty boy Wow yeah go ahead
who do you [ __ ] who you marry yeah
hmm come on Bradley Cooper you saw the
show you looking at me I saw southpaw
and you saw Jake Gyllenhaal money and
[ __ ] Bradley Cooper you can see what
kill two people
go ahead let me hear I'm [ __ ] Bradley
Cooper Wow okay and you're marrying Jake
till she wants about your marriage
what do you say to that from your lips
you want to say something about the
Hodges hopefully that could you turn a
grudge all right I'm sure I know
beet-red proposed me nervous and I told
you you have a promotional woman and
you're like it you have not now all
right that's good you ever bought anyone
a ring no all right you weren't that
alone